m.  Perkins doit être Thomas Wolfe
préfère recevoir mes rejets par la poste mais je
voulais vous rencontrer mec d'abord lire
Hemingway f scott Fitzgerald et dire
Jésus pour que chaque éditeur de fils de [ __ ]
à New York déteste mon livre
mr.  Wolfe nous avons l'intention de publier votre livre
max c'est mrs.  Bernstein m.  Perkins,
c'est la première personne qui m'a dit que mon
écriture valait n'importe quoi en
vous appelant un génie dieu aidez-vous maintenant
je suis un best-seller de Scribner mérite durement un
peu de la hotline max nous dit que
vous travaillez sur un nouveau livre c'est à propos de l'
Amérique tout ça  Je l'ai dans votre stand,
apportez-le les gars,
voilà, nous pouvons le faire pendant combien de temps neuf
mois si vous résistez à la tentation d'en
ajouter plus, je dois pouvoir en ajouter plus,
le livre fait 5 000 pages ou prenez tout
ce qu'il faut.  tu travailles
tous les soirs depuis 2 ans tu sais
ce que c'est que de rentrer à la maison dans un
appartement vide tous les soirs je l'ai perdu au profit de
ton mari tes filles
elles veulent leur père mon travail c'est ce que
je fais depuis deux ans dans les livres  seulement 100
pages plus courtes je t'apporte des trucs que tu
ne ferais pas ça à Hemingway à
Fitzgerald arrête toi de tous les
gens tellement effrayé de vivre d'autres façons
de vivre n'aide pas quelqu'un qui t'aime
Tom parce que nous sommes tous tes millions de
belles  des mots dont tu n'as pas la
moindre idée quoi  ça veut dire être en vie
max pense qu'il m'a créé il m'a paralysé
il a déformé mon monde il a réalisé tous tes
rêves
il t'a donné une carrière
tu l'as fait tu m'as blessé je ne peux pas
tourner le dos au travail
fais ton choix Tom  c'est pourquoi nous, les
éditeurs, perdons le sommeil tu sais que nous
améliorons vraiment les livres
ou les rendons différents toute ma vie jusqu'à
ce que je te rencontre
je n'ai jamais eu d'ami un écrivain comme Tom j'en ai
un dans une vie tu as tes
filles pour la même vie
un paragraphe que je dois ajouter au livre
Mike je dois commencer à cacher des paragraphes
pour fils ce livre est dédié à un
maximum d'efforts Perkins l'auteur espère que
son livre en sera digne